by the way to charge us for we we mean
turkey is another really interesting
example of of this issue to do with
religion and democracy because
essentially what happened was that that
Ataturk was a reaction to the notion
that the religious people should govern
the country but what actually happened
was that the military ended up governing
the country and interfering with the
democratic process the new party in
Turkey that earlier when the present
Prime Minister represents is an
interesting phenomenon because of the
one hand it's trying to take the power
back out of the hands of the military
and the old structures and in that sense
is rather democratic and progressive but
it's also trying to answer a desire
amongst part of the population to
reassert their Islamic identity and so
you've got this curious mixture there
and the question really in Turkey is can
you as this democracy evolves can you
get a political party that is that
really does believe in a state that is
religiously neutral right at the same
time as having sufficient credibility
within the Islamic community of the
country that it's not regarded as
selling out the religious faith and
that's a very interesting it's a very
very interesting question right now